alle kulturen verehren das licht manche
bieten es an
es steht für lebensfreude fortschritt
neubeginn
und so machen wir die nacht zum tag und
begrüßen auch das neue jahr mit licht
wir tragen das licht in die natur und
auch diese zu beglücken
und wenn es mal nicht strahlt und
brilliert sind wir unglücklich
manche sind anders daniel grupp ist ein
leidenschaftlicher spaziergänger und
auch nachts unterwegs
was für eine dimension irgendwo der
kontrast licht und dunkel und auch mal
wir gehen mit auf entdeckungsreise durch
das nächtliche zürich sehen hören und
staunen
durch das dunkel wandern mit daniel
kropf ist eine schule der wahrnehmung
mit allen sinnen so als hätte der
nachtmensch ganz besondere augen und
ohren fantasie mittels quasi weniger so
im volksmund aber dass das gestell
daniel grupp ist verkehrsplaner aber
auch schriftsteller und theaterregisseur
daher sein gespür dafür wie sich der
mensch in szene setzt woher seine liebe
zum licht kommt die angst vor der
dunkelheit bis orange spiel 7 oder im
norden und in der oecd schwarz dunkel
ich ziehe also sind verteilt sind sind
froh und trennten sich geschützt und
sich möglichst zurückzog und führt das
licht wärme und steht eigentlich immer
die angst das feuer
vielleicht die wichtigste erfindung der
menschheit licht wärme und schutz vor
den tieren der dunkelheit aus den
urängsten wurden glaubenssätze das helle
ist gut und das dunkel böse
auch wenn wir heute weniger glauben und
die wilden tiere vor uns schützen müssen
das licht schätzen wir immer noch so
sehr dass wir am liebsten die nacht zum
tag machen unser nachtwanderer sieht
dagegen auch die schattenseiten des
lichts nicht macht ein mensch und im
charité oder also irgendwo quasi alles
nicht mehr es ist fast sicher als als
allzu große differenzen im hell und
dunkel das erste elektrische licht 1878
auf der weltausstellung in paris
die begeisterung war riesig ein turm
sollte als künstliche sonne die ganze
stadt beleuchten
am ende wurde der eiffelturm daraus
die amerikaner bauten tatsächlich montag
mond türme manche stehen bis heute
relikte eines licht fans mit
schattenseiten
daniel gropp kennt zürich seit seiner
kindheit und findet die stadt heute
verändert dunkler angenehmer dank des
blauen linie in zürich seit 2005 umsetzt
dieser beleuchtungs plan vereinheitlich
das nacht bild der stadt weniger licht
effektiver eingesetzt
so ist die grundidee das spart energie
und verringert die lichtverschmutzung
das ökonomische argument war wohl ein
wesentlicher grund zum umdenken
angefangen hatte alles in lyon der
ersten starts mit einem blauen linie
weniger licht und mehr schatten heben
die konturen hervor lassen die
architektur plastischer erscheinen
das macht die stadt attraktiver für
touristen verschont anwohner und
nachttiere vor allzu grellem licht bei
alter und neuer architektur etwa diesem
parkhaus hier
die berühmten versteckten innenhöfe von
lyon wurden erst durch den blauen nie
mehr ins rechte licht gesetzt
zürich war dann die erste stadt der
schweiz die mit einem blauen linie das
verschattete deshalb dunkle wieder
erlebbar machen nicht nur in der
innenstadt auch im modernen stadtteil
zürich west mit der renovierung der
hardbrücke ging auch ein neues
lichtkonzept einher
früher dienten die laternen allein der
beleuchtung und strahlten das licht in
alle richtungen
heute gibt es eigens für die hardbrücke
entwickelte led bänder
sie unterstreichen jetzt die architektur
und strahlen nur dorthin wo licht
gebraucht wird auf den boden weniger
licht soll trotzdem das gleiche
sicherheitsgefühl vermitteln
auf diesem platz sorgen die
unterschiedlichen farben für eine gute
orientierung mit sparsamen eigens für
diesen ort entwickelten lampen
heute meiden wir das allzu quelle dafür
sind wir sensibler im umgang mit licht
geworden
wichtige möglichkeit unter meistens
überschätzt die zum sicherheit bringen
wesentlich wichtiger sind eben andere
sache sie spielt nicht zu belasten
stelle ist der fall ist und dann ist
schön beim raum auch an wasser nur gut
dass man aber in der nacht auf ganz
besondere art wahrnimmt findet erwischt
es ist als hätten auch ihr tag menschen
etwas gelernt in der schule der
wahrnehmung die eigentlich nur der nacht
mensch beherrscht